police in Washington will be on alert
today for possible clashes between
right-wing groups and counter protesters
holding demonstrations in the nation's
capital a demand free speech rally is
planned for Freedom Plaza just a few
blocks from the White House
Natalie brand is in Freedom Plaza this
morning with a preview of how police are
preparing for this Natalie good morning
to you good morning to you Jeff we are
already seeing an extremely heavy police
presence hours before these rival
rallies expected to begin police say
they are planning for safe and peaceful
demonstrations out here but we know that
they will be fully prepared and staffed
in case
tensions do escalate that's what
occurred last weekend in Portland Oregon
as clashes broke out between rallies by
right-wing groups and then counter
protesters one of the groups involved in
that Portland demonstration the
so-called proud boys labeled a hate
group by the Southern Poverty Law Center
is expected to attend the demonstration
in DC today which is called the demand
free speech rally the proud boys even
banned from Facebook because of the
company's policy regarding hate speech
now others scheduled to speak at this DC
event include conservative and
controversial names such as Milo u
nopales and according to the rally's
website former Trump campaign adviser
Roger stone who still remains under a
gag order which actually blocks him from
publicly discussing his ongoing legal
case stemming from special counsel
molars investigation now across the
street from where I'm standing at
Pershing Park is where we are expecting
at counter demonstrators they say their
goal is to outnumber the demonstrators
here as well as to stop the spread of
the alt-right and white nationalism we
know that both demonstrations have been
permitted federal agencies working with
local police to make sure everything
stays calm and under control out here
Jericka Natalie thank you hopefully no
one gets hurt